-Congratulations on the show.
You have --
10 episodes are available
on Netflix now --
another 10 in January.
-Yep.
-You run a weed dispensary
on the show.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Now, you don´t need --
you don´t need to smoke
marijuana to enjoy the show,
but would you --
do you think it would help?
[ Laughter ]
-That´s a loaded question!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well,
all I can tell you is that,
when I read the scripts,
I´m stoned.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um -- and um --
I just wish
I had a seatbelt in bed.
-Oh, you laugh so hard?
-I laugh so hard,
I´m afraid to get up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That is -- I feel like
you´re living the actor´s dream
of just lying in bed, stoned,
reading a script.
That is --
-Isn´t that fantastic?
-You -- Things
have broken right for you.
-Yeah, they really have.
-That is perfect.
-And it´s research!
-Yeah!
You´re actually working
when you´re doing that.
-I really am.
It´s fantastic.
-That´s so exciting.
-Yeah.
-What do you --
now, what about --
you smoke a lot on the show, but
obviously that´s not marijuana.
What are you smoking there?
-No, no, no.
I refuse to smoke
the joints they pack on the show
´cause it´s this horrendous mix
of some kind of herbal stuff
that they --
-Yeah.
-They have to sit there
and cram it into those --
you know, those -- those things.
-Yeah, that´s no good.
-And then things come out
in your mouth.
And so I said,
"I´m just gonna do a vape."
-Okay. Oh, so you´re vaping?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Yeah.
But I´m not vaping real stuff.
-I´m vaping,
like, apricot things --
-Oh, that´s nice.
-You know, but I never inhale.
-Oh, that´s good.
You wait till you´re home.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What about -- now, on --
in the dispensary,
there are all the things --
you know,
this is a fictional dispensary,
but all the things they´d sell
at real dispensaries...
-Yeah.
-...including edibles.
Have you in your life
experienced edibles?
-When I´m desperate.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sure.
-Yeah,
but the thing about edibles is,
you really want it to kick in.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and it´s just
sort of like a stealth bomber.
-Yeah.
-You know?
It´ll kick in maybe
four or five hours later,
and you´re never sure when.
-Yeah.
It´s almost like your friend
who was supposed to bring weed
and is five hours late.
[ Laughter ]
´Cause you just --
Yeah, there we go!
-There we go!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The only problem I have...
-Uh-huh?
Here´s my problem
with edibles --
is I also like
what the edible is,
so, sometimes I-I --
I have one time had a problem
where I just also like
gummy bears.
-Oh, yeah, okay.
I can´t stand --
-So, then --
But I ate
too many gummy bears for --
-How many?
-Well, I mean, four,
but if they´re edibles,
that´s not -- that´s too many.
-Yeah, well, sometimes
I just want chocolate.
-Uh-huh.
-And that´s the only thing
I have there
because I don´t want to eat
chocolate, really.
I don´t go buy chocolate.
-Yeah.
-But if I´m at Dr. Dina´s,
who are our
kind of cannabis consultant...
-Uh-huh.
-She has chocolate, you know,
like chocolate bars.
-Yeah.
-And I just --
Sometimes on a Sunday,
I get desperate.
-Yeah!
[ Light laughter ]
-And I´ll have to have,
you know, a corner of that,
and it´s -- it´s -- it´s deadly.
-It´s deadly.
[ Laughter ]
It´s also deadly and problematic
because you -- you know,
you eat a little,
and you get stoned, and then you
want more chocolate.
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, I never thought about it
that way!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That explains why there´s
none left in the morning.
[ Laughter ]